genius is a word this must be used very
sparingly especially in this world of
films those who claim it who don't have
it and others who do have it that keep
the fact concealed for fear of being
called difficult which usually
translates as unemployable so at one
time or another Orson Welles has been
considered both difficult and
unemployable I know only too damn well
but from the very first from the time of
his very first picture the unforgettable
Citizen Kane Welles mastery of the
medium was evident unfortunately only
once in King was he free to exercise his
talents without restraint subsequent
productions were cut by other hands or
like his Macbeth made on impossibly low
budgets yet in every picture he ever
made his brilliance shone through 30
years ago Orson Welles received from the
Academy what he liked to call half an
Oscar for the script of Citizen Kane
which he co-authored with Herman J
mankiewicz tonight the Academy is
honored to give him an Oscar all his own
earned through his glowing performances
through the inspiration of his direction
and because he is truly that most
difficult unforgivable and invaluable of
God's creations a man of genius
Orson wanted to be here tonight but he's
filming abroad and so he sets in the
medium he loves best film from Europe
mr. Orson Welles ladies and gentlemen
with this great honor may I say that
it's a lot more fun to look forward
looking backward over some 30 years and
the movies is something that I like to
do is seldom as possible but I can't
forget that I didn't spend those years
alone every filmmaker knows how much was
done for him and by how many if I could
call just half of all those who deserve
it to stand beside me now in front of
this camera just to get him in one shot
we'd need Cinerama be quite a crowd
scene as for the public I hope that they
will understand why this is the more
precious just because it does not come
to me from them much less from the
critics but from movie people themselves
the ones who love movies most we need
the public the public doesn't need us
that's the truth of it
we don't really fill a pressing popular
need we try to create it and if we
didn't love movies as much as we do if
we weren't a little crazy on the subject
there wouldn't be any movies at all I
treasure this award as an expression of
this happy lunacy and may I accepted
please not so much for what I may have
done us for what I hope to do God
willing I'm going to make some movies
deserve it meanwhile this encouragement
is very welcome with all my heart I
thank you for it
happy lunacy that's really telling it
like it is on my way back to Ireland
I'll stop in Spain giving this